I'm Barrington and I'm Janice and we're
writing a screenplay I wrote my first
screenplay in 2007 so almost a decade I
wrote my first screenplay with
Barrington about three years ago so
about three years one very valuable
lesson that screenwriting has taught me
is patient I am a career journalist I'm
used to getting a story done in two
weeks three weeks a month tops I've been
working at this for three years so when
Janice brought me on I think the first
summer is she's like we're going to get
this outline done by the end of the
summer and then we're going to have I
think we could be shooting by spring so
the screams that we're working on right
now that we've been working on for three
years is called lovers in their right
mind and I will tell you the truth I'm
writing it because Jen's roped me into
it she's writing it because it's a
subject that's near and dear to her
heart which is I'll let her tell you a
little about it it's on interracial
intercultural and interfaith dating and
relationships and I wrote a book about
that and felt it was very important to
broaden the conversation about how we
can all live together and our
differences I'm a 2am writer i right
when the world is quiet and my thoughts
can focus on something other than the
phone and the emails and the tweets I'm
a warning writer because I have a day
job that starts at noon so i wake up at
about seven and i get about three or
four hours in and then I realized what
time it is
like throw some clothes on and kind of
mad dash out the door and when we get
together rewrite at night and usually
dinner as always involved and it's
usually delicious because Janice cooks
our goal with this script is to finish
writing the script cast the script find
money for the script and make a movie
this is a script that I really can't
quit on because not only are we writing
it but we're producing it and we're
producing it in an environment where
independent filmmaking is looking for
diverse inclusive scripts with unique
storytelling and we've got that I think
one of the greatest things about this
script project for both of us is that
we've gotten an opportunity to meet so
many kinds of different people we've
been able to interact with chefs and
Persian chefs and we've gotten a more
fat and happy and because we're eating
more but we had opportunities to meet so
many other great people in film in other
screen writers directors producers and
it's giving us an opportunity to travel
to Switzerland ones is that we were
selected by this organization called
dream ah go to do their plume ap lick
you a tail atelier Atelier means
workshop in French and so we're going to
go with ten other writers
internationally we were the only
english-speaking script that was
selected and in the early humans one and
the only u.s. one and we're going to
write in a castle for a week in May my
screenwriting goal is to parlay this
into a producing career and produce
everything barrington rights Wow
well yeah I've been churning out some
screenplays for a number of years now i
guess my screenwriting goal is to see
something actually get made that would
be awesome oh and get paid she forgot
the lead good day so this has been fun
yeah but fake them courage it's a great
site and we really appreciate you
considering us we're really excited
about it and thanks